【音樂】
佳中老師
我看到你去循回演講的照片
超誇張欸
天氣很冷
股市很熱
所以想要聽股市的人很多
那個場地是一樓
二樓
都坐滿人
像看歌劇一樣的
有點像歌劇
對啊
對 大家很熱情
很熱情喔
但是我從我們頻道也發現
有很多人因為可能是今年
人家說是去年啦才新開戶的
所以他對很多的技術指標技術現行
他其實一支半截
所以他問出來的問題會讓我們覺得說
其實我們的標古在線等
已經有點境界了
他可能還回到很初階的問題
所以我們今天教一點
基本一點點的
因為他們的問題你看喔
因為我們常常教他們口訣嘛
就頭頭高底底高是多頭
頭頭低底低是空頭
本來我們覺得這很簡單
就好多人留言喔
他都到底什麼是頭頭高低底高啊
是收盤來看嗎
可不可以有人指定一下
請問到底什麼是頭頭高低底高
是看柱子還是高低點
對 然後呢
他就說什麼頭頭高低底高是最高點
和最低點還是收盤
大家都很confused是什麼
怎麼看
然後什麼是頭頭高低底高
沒錯
學股票第一次聽
是不太容易理解啦
我也跟學生講
我開始學這個頭頭高低低高
我也上課上了四次
上四次才知道
我第一次上課也是搞不懂
然後還跟老師辯
我說這個怎麼會
這個都疊了四天
你還說他多頭
你這叛逆耶你
對啊 結果後來搞懂了才知道
這個是回檔
這不是通頭
所以這個當然
各位我們那個前面教學
教頭頭高低低高類級
你還可以多看幾遍
這個就是我們的好處嘛
你就再多看幾遍
上面都有講
是用什麼來計算
是收盤價還是什麼都有講
好都有講
但是今天我們就更簡單
我們來教大家畫線
畫切線
我們今天用一條很神秘的切線
其實這個切線也叫趨勢線
那你一聽就知道
原來這條線就可以看方向
好
所以我們今天的標股在線等
真的是大家非常歡迎的一個單元
朱老師呢
決定呢要來教大家呢
一些比較基本入門的
因為我們現在已經越講越進階了
我們講 MACD 啦
我們講一些大家會覺得比較難一點點
但是今天來教你畫切線喔
因為很多朋友會問說
多頭趨勢叫做頭頭高底底高
我怎麼知道是頭頭高底底高
可能你很熟的人會想說一看就知道啊
可是說真的剛朱老師講了喔
連他都上了四次課
他才高懂什麼叫做多頭的頭頭高底底高
但是如果今天你把這個切線畫出來的話
就很一目了然囉
所以我們今天來教你畫切線好不好
然後你畫好切線
你也會知道一檔股票的壓力支撐嘛
壓力支撐就是一個
好技術線形之本
我們就是要知道他的壓力支撐在哪裡
所以切線的原理到底是什麼呢老師
我們今天特別來跟同學討論切線
好
那其實切線
我們都知道股價有三個趨勢嘛
就是多頭或者是盤整或者是空頭
對 不是升就是盤整就是下降就低
那我們畫一條線你就知道這條線是往上往下還是水平的
你大概就知道這個行情好不好
因為你畫的上升切線如果越陡
當然這個行情就越好
如果好像水平的那這個行情就不好
就盤整了就是橫盤盤整
如果你一化是下來的那麻煩了
那股票就往下跌
是
好 我們預判股價多空運行的方向
還有它會轉強轉弱
所以切線也可以告訴我們支撐壓力
那如果它跌破
當然就表示支撐跌破
你也可以把它
其實也可以用切線做進出做操作
也可以用它來做操作
那我們在前面講操作都講均血
對
跌破5均
5均17 20均
做長一點的20均衍
你就趕快賣
那你也可以用切線
可以用切線
別了以後你再賣都可以
那我們可以提供支撐壓力
這條切線就可以看得出來
切線也還有一個很重要
可以讓你做進場的參考
換句話講
你如果到了切線的邊邊
沒有疊上去
那也是一個買點
因為它是支撐嘛
有支撐向上漲
當然它也是一個買點
所以你也可以用切線來做
做股票
有均線也有切線
老師那你如果均線切線哪一個比較適合做呢
我們大部分人都是在做均線
均線
因為均線它有一個平均成本
大家比較熟悉說
在哪個成本之上
表示大家都賺錢
這個股價比較容易漲
那我們今天來講的是切線
切線我們來看這支股票
最重要就是說
切線 你在如果我們現在畫上升切線
基本上上升切線就是
剛才這個
主持人講的大家分不清多空
如果你把一個股票的兩個低點
最低啦 包括這個下影線
你把它畫起來這條線是向上的
那現在這個就是一個多頭走勢
你畫了這兩個點
因為一條線一畫它就會無限延長
同學自己要畫
因為每一個走勢有不同的低點
所以你要自己去畫
我們這張圖你可以看這麼長時間
這裡都還有支撐
支撐 支撐都還撐在這裡
朱老師那我要怎麼知道我這個圖要抓多長
這條線看起來大概是近半年
六個月
所以我要以一個什麼樣的時間區先來看
等一下我們後面就會詳細的教大家
切線怎麼畫
而且切線它有什麼功能
我們看切線怎麼畫
剛才那張圖各位大概有個印象
如果我們是一個上漲趨勢
就是股價往上走的
我們就畫上升切斜
上升切斜剛才那個看得出來嗎
看得出來
比底高了嗎
對 它是往上跑
你就取兩個低點
兩個低點你連起來
這條線是向上的
那就是上升切斜
如果你找到兩個低點
一畫是向下的
當然就不是多頭了
也就是我們講底底
底底 底底 底底
越疊越低
所以你連的兩條線是向下
那這個當然你就不能做多
所以只要你連的兩條線是向上的
基本上這個就上升前線
所以我們在多頭裡面
記得是連下面的低點
在空頭是連高點
因為空頭我們是看壓力
多頭看支撐
多頭不要疊破
空頭的話你看能不能突破上去
突破不了就繼續空嗎
所以我們在這個多頭裡面
我們是畫低點
那我們看一下這支股票
好我們來畫上升切線
那如果是趙華你看你要怎麼畫
假設走到今天
這就是我的疑問了
因為這邊就有低點
好多低點
對啊所以我可能就會先畫一個這邊的低點
連上去對不對
對
好
但是如果是這邊也可以畫
可以
所以我們剛剛講這低點這低點會往下
所以就不對
這邊不對
但是因為現在往上是從這邊
所以你現在看到你畫的兩個低點是往上的
對
它就會往上跑
這樣連起來
其實你連這個連這個這個叫支撐
對
這邊剛好就撐住
撐住就上去了
對
那這條切線我們叫做原始切線
為什麼呢
因為這邊都是往下
這一個才開始往上
對 才開始
在我們講趨勢這個叫底底高
對不對 開始往上嘛
因為這一底比這一底高了嘛
對 所以你的線現在就往上走了
你的線就往上走了
那骨架會走弱也會走強啊
如果你走強了
你又看到新的低點
對 我也正想問
我也可以這樣畫老師對不對
可以 你又可以畫
可是這一個角度不太一樣
不一樣
那換句話講
有的股票已經走了三個月了
你去畫下面這個就沒什麼意義了
離得太遠了對不對
這個已經跟著離得太遠
已經飛到天上去了
所以你一定要找後最後面的
我最後面這裡有個低點
你往前去畫
你先反過來
我最後有個低點
我往前面那個低點畫
這裡是不是有一條
有
那你現在下面過來就直撐了
因為我們是找後面的支撐
那前面都已經發生了嘛
對
所以這些支撐是你剛開始的時候
比如說這股票空投
那我在這裡也畫了兩個
欸 這時候就看到有支撐了
對
那這地方有支撐
就有可能變多頭了
因為這邊底底高嘛
對
那現在有支撐就頭頭高
它就變多
好 那這個多頭會回檔啊
那回檔我這條切線
就作為支撐的參考
對
那如果它沒有到這條線
那表示你很強
很強一直在上面對不對
你越走越高
你這個低點越來越高
所以你沒有回來
所以你要另外畫
老師可是這樣我還是得判斷
我什麼時候要另外畫
也就是出新的低點
你這個你出了一個新的低點
對
對你吧
對你說出新的低點
那如果沒有出之前
你就只有這兩個低點去畫
出了新的低點
你又去畫這兩個低點
所以上升期限是一直往上走的
所以我們可以一直看到有兩個低點就畫畫看
畫兩個低點就畫畫看
對
那個就支撐
如果跌破就表示你的股票走弱了
沒有那麼強了
那剛才你畫的這個
後面這條是對的
因為我們這有兩個點嘛
所以你一畫
其實這個股票現在也沒有回來
那可能就如果他還是這麼強
我要再找新的時間點畫囉
那如果他現在又上來
你又可以畫新的
那新的現在已經跌三天
你要注意了
要碰支撐了
對
如果碰到這裡有紅的
就代表這個切線有支撐
只要你畫的切線
都一直維持向上
對
那這支股票基本上你就不能做空
你一定是多頭或者是盤整
有時候盤整也會向上
是
因為盤整滴滴高
慢慢墊高這樣子
趨勢最重要
我一直講
我們在交頭頭高滴滴高
也就是在教你趨勢
那現在我們用上升切線
你就簡單一點
我現在走到這我就把低點畫一畫
還在向上 所以你就不能空
然後你去找機會
它不跌破這個支撐上來
你再做
就可以一直做上去
如果這個股票走得越久
你就做得越久
所以這個就是上升切線
下降切線
另外一個叫下降切線
下降切線就是連高點
兩個高點連起來
如果是往下的 那個就是下降切
而且那一家就頭頭低對不對
每一個高點都比上次低了
那這張圖如果要畫下降切
現在要怎麼畫呢
要我的畫呢
就前面先面有兩個高點
我先把它畫起來
因為這邊已經往下了
對
你看到兩個高點是向下
你已經可以開始畫
我先畫第一個
那這個叫原始下降切
就第一條
因為你前面的高點去畫畫看
是向上的
對 它是多頭走勢
對 頭頭高
對不對 你兩個高點畫是向上
所以絕對不能空
那現在不是
出現了兩個低點
兩個高點是往下
兩個高點往下
那反過來不能多
你不能跑進去買多
因為它已經頭頭低了
那這個是產生什麼作用
是壓
所以你看到後面這個地方
這個地方就壓
它只要遇到壓就上不去
遇到壓就上不去
那就準備空
因為它是空頭
那你空頭要找什麼位置
就是預壓過不去的時候
來通它
跌下來的時候
所以我們如果仔細的去看就很清楚
你連著這兩個剛好這邊就是壓
那你怎麼知道是壓
因為這是黑K
然後它不就下來了
所以在這邊如果過不去的話
我們就準備要通了對不對
那現在的問題就來了
我這個是新的高點
那你跟前面的連起來
跟原來的一條是一樣的
沒有變
對你在下降切線就沒有變
它就這樣子一直這樣
如果你下次沒有到這裡就下來
你就有新的高點
這個高點跟前面就會有另外一條
那你就去看後面的一條
隨時改變
隨便改變
切線是跟著它走的時候
你就跟著自己畫
你會畫你就可以看到很多
很多有用的東西
那我現在畫出來了對不對
畫出來我要運用啦
我要怎麼運用很重要
我們剛才那幾張圖
各位已經知道它有支撐嘛
對不對
下次你畫了回到這個地方你就注意一下
第二個走勢強弱就看你畫的線的角度
剛開始的底底高
後來又畫的角度越來越大
所以當你畫的角度越大
你的股票就越強
可是後面因為我們講後面你會一直畫
你會發現後面畫的角度變小了
那就是股票變弱了
角度越強 咬度越斜 股票越強
後面畫畫畫S怎麼變平了
就股票變弱 走勢變弱
但是因為它雖然變得角度小
但是因為它還是向上
所以它還是多頭
對 它還是多頭 你不能空
不要空它
只能說你的多單停立趕快走
因為你賺到了
但你不能空
再來跌破最後的切線
所以你有一些最後的切線
就你畫的最後那一條
多頭上漲就開始減弱
那回檔修正
又把前面那一條
我們不是在畫嗎
1 2 3 4
你把第四條跌破了
你又把第三條跌破了
那你就連跌兩條
那這時候你的趨勢大概就改了
大概就要改變
所以基本上啦
你在跌破第一條
應該大部分都應該要離場
因為這個叫最後切形
剛剛老師有講
我連的前兩點
前兩個是原始的切線
從原始切線
你畫第一條 第二條 第三條 第四條
畫到可能就最後一條叫做最後切線
第四條 最後一條嘛
那你一疊破就轉弱
但疊破第二個
對 結果它疊了以後還不停啊
它又把第三條又疊破
大概這個趨勢就會轉
也就是你上來要現在反過來
你做多要小心
可能過不了了
可能要平立了對不對
所以我們切線呢
因為它是支撐嘛
我們在支撐壓力的理論上有講
任何一個支撐如果跌破就會變壓力
所以我們講你最後一條跌破
那你在上漲
你跌破的那一條就變壓力線
所以你到那個位置小心一點
好不好
那剛才的這個我們畫在圖上
你就比較容易
好 就懂我們剛才在講什麼了
因為我們一直改變切線嘛
對
你這邊都是空頭嘛
好 就是下降了
你畫低點沒意義嘛 是往下嘛
那你現在看到這個角跟這個角
你畫的線是往上
這裡有個水平線
這條是水平的
那你現在畫的這一條是往上
已經開始上升了
也就是骨架不疊了
它開始往上走
這是第一條
然後呢
它多頭回檔再漲
又有新的低點
這是新的嘛
新的再連一次
你在往前面連
這是第二條
然後這個回檔這是第二條
回來又有一個點
再連一次
這第三條
然後這裡又有一個點
這是第四條
喔 越來越抖
可是第四條這邊有支撐
它撐住了
所以你的第四條還沒有變
還是這一條
然後再來這裡又上漲
第五條出現了
然後它回檔囉
喔 跌破第五條囉
但是它還是多頭
因為你跌破了是不是有新的地點
我跟前面的連這條綠色的線
這是第六條
可是你沒有發現
第六跟第五角度變小了
對
它往下跑了
所以你的股票沒有那麼強
它是多頭蛋變弱的
你看前面多好
角度越放越大
越放越大
那這個就開始有訊號了
所以我們講一個股票要轉弱
你就開始注意
哎呀
我後面在做
會不會有
會不會還會大漲
對
對不對
還是越來越弱
因為它已經走弱了
好 那現在多頭回檔
這一疊把第四條又疊破
這是第五條
這是第四條
然後再一上漲
這兩個低點變平了
我後面的第七條
是平行線了
這個角度從第五條到第六條
到第七條
所以你看你的股票已經頭頭低了
已經開始
有出現變空頭的訊號了
容易疊破
所以我們就去注意一下這四個
那剛才為什麼會講說
跌破這個會轉弱
因為這條就會變壓力
這條就會變壓力
因為這個跌破
現在我上漲就碰壓
碰到第五條就上不去了
就變壓了
那我現在又跌破第四條
第四條又變壓力了
所以你就變成頭頭敵了
沒跌破它都是支撐
跌破了它就是壓力
這叫支撐壓力的轉換
所以我們的切線如果你能夠畫
那你慢慢的就可以抓到這個訣竅
抓到這個訣竅
那這也就是告訴我們說
你再做一支股票
假設其實這支股票原始上人切線
應該是在這個低點
最低點嘛
那它實在是滿平的
但是它是很平
而且這個還沒有過高
那現在過高了
所以你有新的啦
你就畫了
所以老師大概這張圖也是抓半年左右的
然後你化了以後就做後面的參考
後面這邊有支撐
有支撐
而且都不離不遠
而且看起來都沒有跌破
這時候跌破了
其實你看你的股價20幾塊
已經走到3幾塊了
也超過5成
所以我剛剛有講
你如果用切線做操作
可不可以
我在這裡買了
我就這條切線
我這裡已經出現切線了
只要你不跌貨我就一直報
抱著你碟破我就賣了
所以你抱著這麼大一段
能力也是操作得很好
那有的股票因為它不強了
你看長一根就碟嘛
長一根就碟
那如果你是用五軍的話
你就很心疼
就會一直出場進場
出場進場
對啊對啊
那我不如花一條切線
對
你沒有碟破我就抱
那碟破我就走
所以切線比較是趨勢
是不是
是是
切線是比較長線在做
做比較長的長線
ok嗎
所以你從這個就可以知道
為什麼這你要賣
第一個你獲利很高了
第二個它走了很久了
第三個黑黑疊破
它疊破了就變成壓力囉
所以你這邊要是再上來
這個就要小心
就變壓力了
如果變壓力這個頭就過不了
那它就容易翻轉
是
其實這個廠商引線爆很大量
這已經很接近這個壓了
這個就變成壓力
好
再來看一檔
我們看第二張圖
各位就會知道說
一樣喔 這邊是底底底嘛
所以不能畫
畫了一定是往下的
往下 就空頭
你畫到這個才看到往上嘛
對
對不對
那如果你畫了這個往上
那後面有新的 你要畫新的
因為後來他長得比較急
就出現了新的地點
所以你會發現綠的角度
比藍的角度要大
所以這邊比較強
可是強的股票就不能跌破
好 他就先跌破綠的
跌破 綠的
所以如果你在這裡操作
在這裡做
在你這個就先
走一趟
因為這個要轉弱了
結果再回來前面這條又疊破
所以基本上已經沒有了
好這個趨勢沒有了
所以我們比較
如果你在短線上就是最後這一條
最後那條一疊破你叫提高警覺
是
這樣子對你的操作就有幫助
好不好
好所以這個是在上升過程中
骨架已經反轉了
對
那如果是往下走是同樣的道理
各位都可以舉一反三你把它反過來
等於是股價在下跌的過程中
在下跌中你想說
這個股票到底好不好
可不可以做多
可不可以減啊
對不對 還是要去做空啊
如果你把兩個高點一連是往下的
這個就叫下降切線
剛才我們的高點連的都向上
那是上升趨勢
那你現在兩個高點連的向下
所以它有壓力了
我們剛才已經講過
你只要一跌破切線
那個切線就有壓
那現在你又在切線下面
所以它就有壓
一樣的你一直畫一直畫
後面的高點一直畫一直畫
那個角度越來越往下
那你的股票就越來越弱
基本上我們如果你是做空的
你就一直抱著
因為它一直往下走
做空就希望它一直往下
即使有反彈下來
你的切線還是在往下
它過不了切線的壓力
它就下去了
就一直抱
所以切線是因為它是趨勢線
所以其實是看一個長方向
那一樣的突破最後的切線
你畫的最後那條
你的空頭開始轉強
轉強就要留意囉
你的空單要注意囉
因為你還是不能做多
因為它還是還在往下
其實就相反的概念
多單你跌破第一根的支撐的時候
你先不要做空
但是你多單要撿嘛
反之你的空單可能這時候要先撿嘛
先回補
空單先回補
那你這個如果這條下降切線被突破
還會疊嗎?因為你還是空頭啊
你在疊的時候這條會變支撐
你就要小心一點
所以跟剛才的道理是剛好反過
做空就怕它越變越強
沒錯
剛好這條是水平的
現在我這兩個高點變成往下的
我就畫自己一條
剛開始疊的時候緩疊
對 然後有新的高點我就畫一條
變成疊有點急了
對 你就畫角度越變越大
那你的股票就跌得越來越遠
做空就開心了
當然做多這個千萬你早就該出場了
做多
做多這早就改變趨勢了
做多就是沒有看節目
告訴你頭腦筋
告訴你很多人不死心 朱老師
那跟技術分析沒關係
技術分析我很難教你是不死心
我沒辦法教你
我只告訴你這個已經變空了
空頭了
那你做空
只要你每次新的高點
一直往下畫
其實一直坐下去
你就一直往下畫
可是現在的反彈
就把最後這五條給突破了
他突破壓力囉
你還要抱就要稍微注意囉
因為這個再疊下來就會變支撐
支撐在一彈
第四條又疊破了
就在前面
又站上了
又突破了
那你又變支撐
你就看底底高就好
他要轉成多頭了
這時候考慮要做多單
其實我們在看趨勢很簡單
你看到底底高就開始往上畫
你看到頭頭低就往下畫
你這兩條線畫了就OK了
就解決了
我如果底底高我就往上畫
那結果你一回檔跌破我就跑了
也許他只走一段
不一定股票沒有人說
每個都要走很遠
可是我有條線
等到你頭頭低我就往下畫
你也許在這裡就突破了
突破就走了
所以這兩條線其實是很好用的
其實技術分析真的就沒有絕對啦
很多會說我怎麼現在看這個趨勢
我怎麼還賠錢
因為趨勢改變了
趨勢改變了 圖改變了
你的心態你的做法就要改變了
不是說你畫一條趨勢線
他就照你的線走不是
本來就會改變
有人會以為畫這條線
他就該這樣走其實不是這樣子的
一定當時的狀況
那有的可以走三年多
有的只守三天
就變出了 就變啦
就變啦
我們就是
為什麼要畫圖就是跟著趨勢走
不然我沒有圖我也不知道你趨勢變
對不對 那就真的用猜的
所以我有圖就不用猜
所以大家就很客觀
就是你跟我看的這支股票
大家看都一樣
他是空頭嘛
大家都知空頭
那最後有一個很有用的叫極切線
為什麼叫很有用
因為最近都還蠻急的
因為很多人都做到標股了
對 因為我們叫標股在線等
沒錯 那做到標股了
大家又有一個很急的事
就不知道怎麼賣了
經常會問老師我這個要不要賣
要不要賣
我說你天天賺錢還那麼緊張
對不對
你說賠錢要問了要不要賣
因為很多人心態
還是怕沒賣到最高點
對 但是很難
但是我可以告訴你
賣到相對的高點
ok 那我們就用切線
但這個切線跟剛才不一樣
因為剛才我們講趨勢
所以趨勢是找高點跟低點
轉折的高點跟低點
但是這個極切線就不死了
極切線因為你長得很急
那我就用
k線的低點
每根k線的低點去畫
那疊破
如果往上的話 疊破就表示
它要回檔了 那你就可以賣
極切線是短期連續
連續下跌K線的高點
那這是往下的
或者連續上漲的低點
我們都有講上漲連低點嘛
剛才也是嘛
下跌連高點嘛
那你連了這個幹嘛呢
就是超短期股價變化化的切線
作為短線進出的參考
我怎麼覺得大家對這個會很有興趣
因為最近急漲急跌的股票非常多
所以你要其實這也是告訴我們
怎麼應變
你天天長你都可能有一天認為
他不會疊了
解釋說類天一疊很容易就會疊下
還有最重要就是你要獲利入代
你不知道
如果他真的很急
有時候武軍的怪力都會變大
因為他每天拉嘛
那個武軍就怪力大
那你疊破武軍也是一個方法
我們說短線嘛
疊破武軍
可是你疊破武軍就少賺了
大概又少賺一根了
那我們可以用極切線
你用極切線出廠
所以極切線用在什麼地方
極長極疊標戶
還有陌生段的噴出
還有我們講這個微型反彈
對不對
你要去搶這個反彈
因為反彈是歷史嘛
所以你就化極切線
它疊破你就趕快買
還有上下幅度的盤整區
我們講這個盤整區很大
那我想上面空 下面補
那你這個只有一段
所以你就去畫極切線
他只要一上來你就補
好
這幾個功能都可以用極切線
好 用極切線
我們也來舉例好不好
我們最近很標的古很多嘛
我們的貨櫃行員
有人留言給我們
說朱老師我的貨櫃翻船了
沒有翻船
翻船
翻船喔
對 翻船了
趨勢不要變
各位看剛才講的第一點話
跌破速度轉弱了
跌破這邊就會變壓
對 可是他也蠻厲害的
馬上就突破
變壓了但是趨勢沒有改
這個是頭頭低
但是我畫的這條還在向上
以上升切線來看
他的趨勢其實沒變
我們剛剛不是講了嗎
你現在這裡有沒有新的低點
有嗎
這裡有沒有新的低點
可以連起來的
這裡有沒有你前面的低點
但是其實還是底底高
對 你去畫你就放心了
他還是底底高
你看你還是放心了
對不對
表示這你沒有破
那現在又上來了
上來了現在的這條上升界限
當然沒有破
對你又有支撐
所以今天
今天是進場
今天開進場
為什麼我們以後不要收盤後錄影
這是多頭嗎
所以這是我教的
我要跟製作人說
我們以後收盤
我們盤中錄影
然後就等一下我一下就錄影
儘管會要查
就變代表了
這個就是我現在教你
你以後就自己把它先畫出來
畫出來你如果這個紅的疊破了
就剛才講轉弱了
對不對
剛才不是講嘛
這個上升接線不能疊破
那現在上來就沒有疊破
那你現在又上來了
而且還上到月線上
你還跑在月線上
所以這是我們今天進場的位置
在這邊好不好
那所謂的極切線就是
連續下跌的高點
那各位看這個高點
一突破就表示不跌了
它開始往上走了
這個就是連續上
那這樣子如果你有急漲急跌
我們就可以去看
那這個是一個長期的上升切線
所以萬海還沒有破
只是它的股價很高了
漲得急了啦
下面大概萬海我記得十幾塊吧
這邊已經拉得很高了
所以只是在這裡
你只要按照紀律
如果上去這個沒有過
因為他進到盤或者頭頭低了
但目前趨勢還沒有反轉
遇到支撐是有撐的
這個就更有感覺了
這個他已經被限制
20分鐘一盤囉
那這個很多同學假設你做到
長到這裡你大概心就有點怕了
哇這個已經長45天了
老師要不要罵
大概每天都在問這個
那我說你為什麼要問呢
他說我怕他跌啊
我說你跌
你賺錢又多麼好怕了
人家賠錢才怕嘛
他說賺多了也會怕
那我說很簡單
有兩個方法
一個當然就是我們講的跌破五均
那還有一個方法
你就把K線的低點
其實這個不太標準
就低點在這
這個低點
你就把K線的低點化
然後記得要黑K的十體棒跌破
黑K的十體棒
那這個下影線不算
也許你在這裡畫
你會看到一個
這個下影線也不算
收盤可以碟破
就在這賣
那這就碟破啦 對不對
就減弱啦
所以你就可以賣
那賣了以後
那你就
這一段就先獲利啦
對
就是急漲急跌
你這一段就先獲利了嘛
但是趨勢沒有改
他趨勢還沒改嗎
跌那麼大
因為你今天又漲
那今天是不是有低點
有
跟前一個低點再連起來
前面那個低點在這
喔 畫一個新的趨勢線
對
他只是沒有辦法長這麼急了對不對
對 還有畫
沒有那麼抖了
沒有那麼抖了嘛
因為你那一段飆太久了
對 好
所以我們就沿這條線做
你就沿這條線做
好 不能再跌破囉
對 如果來這邊跌破
你就趕快離開
如果沒有跌破
你就一直抱一直抱一直抱
就變成又有一條新的
又有一波了
新的上升切線
對 因為獲利數字看起來滿驚人的
對 外資一直調高目標價
不知道為什麼大家就不
股票漲總是有原因嘛
對不對
他既然漲一定是背後還在
還在這個利多
還有他的story
還有他的故事
對 還在利多
所以我們常講
切線切線切切切
你沒事就去還切一切
那這條線如果你能夠用的比較熟
你隨時可以抓到支撐壓力
轉強轉弱你都可以看
心情也比較安定啦
不要那麼害怕
當然 因為這是最短的一條線
就是改變的時候最快的
最快就是這一條
這個趨勢還早嘛
這個回檔還要
還要頭頭低
還要底底才變空
所以這條是最早
讓你能夠趕快先跑掉
好 那現在也還沒有改變趨勢
也不要太難心
好 那接下來呢
今天大家上完了切線
因為切線算是比較入門的
而且真的你只要把兩個低點
或兩個高點
連成一條線
其實就可以開始畫了
然後但是不要忘記你要隨時改變你的方向
因為他可能越長越急
他也可能越疊越深
好 當然不要忘記了
我們的標古在線等
一直都有進階的課程
我們會畫了切線之後
還有一條線更神秘
它是一條軌道
那這個軌道可以讓你更清楚知道說
我怎麼樣沿著這一條通道
抓到我的買賣點
但這個會在我們的榮耀班
請大家積極加入我們的榮耀班
今天非常謝謝朱老師
教我們切線的畫法
以前趙華也是常常會覺得
切線好像很難 我就不管他
然後但是其實他好簡單喔
你可以先畫原始切線
就是第一個低點跟第二個低點
如果他是往上 低點已經往上跑了
就可以上升切線了 對不對
高點 第一個高點
第二個高點 如果他往下跑了
就可以畫下降切線
欸 真的很簡單
拿出你的紙跟筆跟尺
來先畫畫看好不好
當然如果跟著股票的漲跌的趨勢變化
你的切線也要隨時做改變喔
它會不停的提醒你
你的壓力在哪裡 你的支撐在哪裡
住股票就不用再害怕了
所以今天的標股在線等
教你切線入門
希望你們都有學起來囉
那我們下次再見了 拜拜